Welcome back.
Now I think that hopefully you
have some intuition, and maybe
you can figure this out
on your own, but I'll
show how to do it.
We spent a lot of time on how
fast did I throw the ball--
how fast was it when it left my
hand-- so let's figure out
how high did it go, because
that's kind of a cool thing to
know, as well.
We figured out that the final
velocity-- actually, the
initial velocity-- is just
equal to minus the
acceleration of gravity
times time over 2.
If we say that the acceleration
of gravity is
minus 10 meters per second
squared, then this becomes
5t-- so that's initial velocity,
and the final
velocity is just the negative
of the initial velocity.
It's going back to what
we were doing before.
The initial velocity--
we want to figure out
how high did we go?
Let's just go back to our
basic-- we want to figure out
this point, and we want
to figure out how high
did this thing go.
That's actually the for vertex
of this parabola, and if you
know the formula for a vertex of
parabola, you could do it--
once again, I like to do it
intuitively, as opposed to
memorizing formulas.
We want to figure out how
high did this go--
let's call that h.
So what happens?
I'm going from an initial
velocity of vi, and I'm going
to a final velocity-- well, not
a final velocity, you can
call this an intermediate
velocity-- a velocity of 0.
It takes a time of t sub naught
over 2-- that doesn't
look too good-- it takes
t over 2, or t
sub naught over 2.
I know it gets confusing when
it's t sub naught-- t sub
naught just says this is an
actual constant t as opposed
to just the variable t,
and that's all it is.
I know it can get confusing
sometimes.
So, the initial velocity is
equal to minus g times
whatever we time, or
whatever time your
friend gets on the timer.
But we also know that between
time 0 and t sub naught over
2-- so half the time that your
friend has on the timer-- the
velocity went from this
velocity to 0.
The average velocity over that
time-- not the average
velocity over the entire time,
the average velocity over just
this first interval-- the
average velocity here would
just be v sub i plus 0, because
we're kind of this
intermediate velocity, because
we're stationary up here, so
we divide that by 2.
v sub i is just this, so if we
take this, and substitute
here, we get their average
velocity over this time
interval is equal to
minus g times t sub
naught over 4, now.
Remember, this is only the
average velocity over this
time period-- the average
velocity over the entire time
period over t sub naught is
actually 0, because we start
and end at the same place.
This is kind of an interesting
point as to how speed and
velocity is different.
You're probably thinking--
hey, Sal, how could the
average velocity over the entire
time be 0, when the
ball was clearly going quite
fast most of the time?
That's the difference between
speed and velocity.
It turns out that the speed was,
I agree with you, quite
fast the entire time, but when
you take the average velocity,
all the times that the velocity
was positive, is
balanced off by the times that
the velocity is negative.
Over the entire period, the
average of the velocity is 0,
and that makes sense because,
the ball didn't go anywhere--
it just came back to where it
started, and so that's an
interesting distinction between
speed and velocity.
Anyway-- going back, and I hope
I'm not confusing you--
the average velocity over this
time period is minus g times t
sub naught over 4.
If we were to graph it here,
that would be right here-- it
would be essentially this,
at this point.
This is our average velocity
over half the time period, and
it would be equal to
v sub i over 2,
which is equal to this.
We know our average velocity
over this time period, and we
also know the time-- the time is
t sub naught over 2, so we
can just say change in distance
is equal to average
velocity times time.
What's the average velocity?
It's all this stuff minus
gt sub naught over 4.
The average velocity is this,
and what's the time?
We're saying the average
velocity over t sub naught
over 2, not the whole t sub
naught-- maybe if I do some
examples with numbers, this
won't be as confusing.
So, the time is t sub
naught over 2.
So t sub naught over 2.
That's the time.
And so the distance we traveled,
h, is equal to-- if
we multiply it out-- minus gt
sub naught squared over 8.
That's interesting.
If I throw a ball, and so this
is h-- I know I'm making this
really crowded-- if I throw a
ball, and it takes 5 seconds
to go all the way up, and
go all the way down.
If I just substituted in this
equation so that it takes 5
seconds to go all the way up,
and all the way down-- once
again, this is minus g, so if
gravity is actually a minus 10
meters per second, so this
becomes a positive.
Going back, if I say h is
equal to-- so minus g is
positive 10 meters per second
times 5 seconds.
It's 10 times 5 over 8, so
40 over 8 equals 50--
oh, sorry, t squared.
I was about to say something,
because that's
not right-- t squared.
It's minus g t naught
squared over 8.
So what's 10 times 25?
It's 250 over 8, so that's
30 something meters--
it's like 31 meters.
So if I can throw a ball, and
it stays in the air for a
total of 5 seconds, I threw it
31 meters into the air-- that
might not sound high, but
31 meters is 93 feet.
That's equivalent to a nine
story building, so that
actually is pretty high.
If you can if you can keep a
ball in the air for 5 seconds,
you're pretty strong.
I want to show you something
else that's kind of
interesting, or at least
interesting to me.
Let me erase some of this,
just because I think it's
getting really crazy now.
Let me erase this stuff.
See, I'll even erase
this stuff.
I think you get it now, and
you can just back up and
rewatch it-- that's the beauty
of these videos.
You don't really have to take
notes, but just back it up and
rewatch the video.
OK.
I think I have a clean
space now.
So let me just do a
nice color, and
back to the pen tool.
We got that the height is
equal to minus gt naught
squared over 8, but we could
have also written this as--
I'm just playing around with
this algebraically-- this is
the same thing as minus g over
2 times t naught squared-- t
naught over 2 squared.
This is just the exact
same thing.
I was wondering, does this
concept look familiar?
Well, sure.
This is in our distance equation
that we did before,
where we just say that that
change in distance is equal to
the initial velocity times time
plus at squared over 2.
This term right here looks an
awfully lot like this term,
and this would be equivalent
to this equation if this
initial velocity was 0.
So how does this relate?
Another way to think about it
is this distance that you're
traveling up, it's also the same
distance-- maybe just the
negative-- of the distance
that you travel down.
If we said that we're starting
at this point, at this point
the ball is stationary, so it's
identical to just taking
that ball, and dropping it.
If we say that we're going to
drop a ball from height h, how
long does it take?
Then we can use this formula.
If I drop a ball from height h,
the change in distance is
going to be minus h, because
it's going to go from height h
to 0, and so we could say that
minus h is equal to-- the
initial velocity is
going to be 0.
Whoops!
I'm over time.